Hey comedy, huh? Whoo. Still not really sure what this is,
but I'm glad to be here. It feels like a comedy show,
but it looks like a porn shoot. Uh, just confused.
I feel bad for kids. So much stimulus coming at kids. I phone internet,
social media. Remember I have to go lucky where his kids,
not a care in the world. Maybe run to the car. Shotgun.
That was like the biggest problem. My life shotgun. Yeah.
I never see kids doing that anymore.
The only time a kid yells it out now is in a classroom.
A lot of racial talk now white privilege. That's a term.
We hear a lot now white privilege, but I thought it was all about diversity.
So should we talk about everybody's privileges? Why?
We're just limiting it to Whitey. Let's spread the love.
Let's make every group feel good. Everybody's got something to all people.
Privileged seat. A concert Jews. No. Hell
pretty good. Pretty good women. Ladies night. That's cool.
Black people. I can't wear a purple suit. Can't keep up with the terms.
You know, some PCI leg like native American. That's good. He's not from India.
Where are we going in India? Native American grade. I'll say that,
but like African-American I feel weird saying I don't mean African-American
friends. I have black friends, only Caucasian friends. I have relatives.
None of it adds up. We're only African Canadians. Why don't we say that?
Black people born Cain every day.
We don't know what the hell we're saying anymore.
We'll be like Ijaz Elvis and amazing African-American actor. Well, he's British.
Yeah. I think white people just scare to say in the word black.
We're just trying to avoid that at all costs. We don't get in trouble. You know,
you could corner a white guy with a microphone, a video camera.
Like what color is Ray? Charles? He'd be like, ah, he's blind.
What's his ethnicity? Piano player. What color is his skin? I got kids, man.
Come on.
I think we're all sick of this though. We're all. I mean,
Corona is kind of like the check engine light. You know,
when you first hear about it, you're like, this is terrifying.
And after a while you're like, I gotta get to work. I mean,
this is a tough time in history for black people,
black people are going through it.
The two people have a tough right now where black people and women named Karen,
they were having a tough.
Go. Um, but.
Yeah. Yeah. Bore black women. They're they're they're yeah,
they got hit hard by the disease. You know,
which I'm shocked by because black are so strong. I'm surprised.
I thought they'd be fine with illness. I mean, look at magic Johnson.
He's still kicking. He's doing great. Hell he beat Coby.
I know who saw that coming.
Yeah. You got to live life books. Yeah. I know.
Blackpool or getting sick. I blame institutionalized racism and elaborate.
Handshakes. Come on. I told an abortion joke recently and a woman approach me.
She was like, Hey, that's very insensitive. I've had an abortion.
You shouldn't tell jokes like that. I was like, Whoa, Hey, sorry.
I just told a joke. I think what you did was much.
Worse.
Yeah. You guys can say a lot of stuff.
Like my last girlfriend dumped me said I wasn't manly enough for her.
Not a manly guy. That one hurt. I know we're allowed to say stuff like that.
Like I'm all about equality, but how can a woman can say something like, yeah,
like guy was good with his hands. He could fix stuff around the go. You're cool.
But if a guy says, Hey, I like what would been cooked? People go, Whoa, Whoa.
It's not the fifties. Well, how come her drive for me is okay.
But my job for her is that okay.
Also who doesn't like somebody who can fix around the house.
I'd love to come home. My girlfriend's like, Hey, but it was a Dick ride.
Awesome. I'll do laundry. See, I think women are you're.
You guys are so smart because you guys made your gender roles offensive.
Yeah. That was very clever.
Well played ladies. Well-played guys. How great would that be?
If we could offend a Negro up and wake up at 4:00 AM. I heard glass shattering.
Somebody break in. You're like, well it's not the fifties. Go check it out.
My ex-girlfriend very paranoid. Always going through my phone. Sock drawer,
sniffing me, always looking for clues.
That's why I'm surprised you don't see more female detectives, ladies.
You guys would be amazing at that. You guys are intuitive. You're curious.
You're persistent. I feel like you gals would crack every case.
As long as you thought it was personal. That's the key like, man,
this guy killed 18 people in Fresno.
So what he's also cheating on your best friend. Give me the file.
See the problem with the phone is this they'll cut off. Like with booze,
you drink too much. Somebody goes, Hey, you've had enough.
Or your body cuts you off. You pass out. You just fall down.
You puke phone. No cutoff. We need like a phone bouncer. There's a guy like,
Hey, you can't get it. And you're like, but that's mine. That's big.
It's my place. Oh, I heard a phone.
Um, I don't, I'm just some way on my phone. Way more than booze.
Like I've never been like, Oh, I gotta take a. Where the hell is my cocktail
for six. I can't have a cocktail. No cargo for six minutes. It's insane.
All right. Um, we'll keep it moving. You look.
You don't believe me.
And then after six minutes on the toilet,
you don't ask why you don't have a car.
That's the joke. Just shut up.
We'll talk later. All right. Um, cool. All right.
Hopefully, uh, what the hell was I talking about? Oh yeah.
So yeah, the gaze.
Yeah. It was just so sexy and drive me crazy.
I want to just want to put stuff in. Yeah. Oh,
you're so hot with your wacky Libya. I love it. Yeah. This is um,
this is how sexy girls are. I was up at dinner.
Once this girl leans over during the meal and goes, Hey,
I'm not wearing any underwear. I was like, Oh my God, that's hot.
Then I realized, why is that sexy as underwear?
Everybody who jobs before a guy has any guy ever taken a girl's jeans off,
seen pain? He's been like, Ooh, it's going to be a long night.
When a pot of coffee on, I can't crack that code. Let's go hot. You are girls.
You can tell by article of clothing. You're not wearing.
I can't even see it missing. I'm already turned on. Yeah.
That's a word for me as a guy. I can't pull that off. I lean over during dinner.
Hey, I'm not wearing any underwear. She's going to go up. Oh, what happened?
Monitor day. Diarrhea. Need a wet wipe. Talk to me.
Seems like a lot of people are quitting. The booze now it's kinda going away.
All my friends are getting sober. Look. That's good.
But some people are better when they're drinking.
There's a lot of bad sobers out there. Yeah.
We always start with the negative part about booze. What about the good,
like sure. You drove through a playground, but you could dance, man.
I try not to make fun of fat people unless they make fun of me.
That's when I let it go. Yeah. Like all my fat friends give me.
One of my frat friends told me I have skinny privilege.
Like privilege something. Can't be a privilege if you could do it too. Ah,
pedophilia. Huh? Any pedophiles here?
I mean, statistically, it's gotta be too. Right. But Hey, we're all adults here,
which is a sentence they hate.
Yeah. Comedy comedy,
comedy comedy. Huh? Thanks a lot. I'm Kevin Hart and have a good night.
Thanks a lot. I'm Kevin Hart. Kevin. Thanks a lot.
Kevin, Kevin Hart have a good night. Thank you.